All right, let's talk about the deal.
Let's talk about step three of the perfect prospecting script, which is explaining the
deal.
What is in it for them and what is in it for you?
And as I've talked about already, the more important part of this equation, which is
what's in it for the business owner and what's in it for you, it's way more, although it
sounds counterintuitive, it's way more important for you to explain to them clearly what's
in it for you than what's in it for them, because they already know what's in it for
them.
Okay.
They're already expecting you to shower them with reasons why it's a good deal for them.
But very, very few people, in fact, no one explains what's in it for the person calling.
So for example, home advisor, all they do is they call and they say, hey, you're going
to get, I'm going to give you leads, blah, blah, blah.
They don't turn around and say, hey, the reason that we're doing this is because we make a
shitload of money off of selling leads.
Okay.
Because guess what?
If they did that, they'd sell a whole lot more leads if they just said that.
But instead it's always like, oh no, we're just such good people.
And guys, that's the same reason you guys have been on calls with me.
That's the same reason why I tell you, hey, I'm going to take care of you.
I am going to over deliver.
I know you're expecting me to say that, but guess what?
Here's what's in it for me.
If I over deliver, I am going to grow this group and I am going to make a lot of money.
And I have no shame in talking about it.
I got no bones saying that.
Okay.
And when I say that, you respect it.
You're like, okay, that's what I thought anyway.
I'm glad he owns it.
Okay.
So I just wanted to point that out.
Do not be shy telling them, hey, this is what's in it for me.
Okay.
This do not, do not be shy.
Do not feel like you need to lie.
Do not feel like you need to hide.
Do not feel like you need to pretend to be a good person or that you're just helping
out.
I like to help local business owners.
Bullshit.
Okay.
You're here to make money.
They don't know.
They already know you're going to do that.
Okay.
I just want to point that out.
Let's dive in.
So guys, going back a little bit, the last thing that we did before we transitioned is
we explained, Mr. Business Owner, Jack, the reason I called you is because I saw you're
running paid ads on Google.
So I know you're hungry to grow.
Now we transition and we're going to transition.
The first thing we're going to do is we're going to tell them that we have a hot lead
for them and that we want to give them a couple leads in exchange for a conversation.
Okay.
Yeah.
So Jack, I'm merging these a little bit, but we get done.
Hey, the reason I'm calling you is because you're running ads.
So here's the deal is the reason I'm calling you, you know how I mentioned Silver Beach
Circle?
Yeah.
I have a lady.
Her name is Janet.
She needs a tree removed.
This just actually came through my website.
That's why I was calling you.
I want to give you this job.
Literally.
It costs you nothing.
I'm going to do it.
I don't care if you don't even return my call.
Okay.
However, I do want to mention this.
What I would like to do and the reason I called you specifically is I am looking for an ongoing
partner.
Okay.
Make no mistake about it.
I would like to give you this one, but I'd also like to give you about three to five
of these to just test out.
All I would ask in return, and the reason I'd be willing to do that is I would love
to talk about possibly working together in a couple of days or maybe a week, whenever
I can get you a couple of jobs.
Would you be open to that?
If I could just give you a couple for no charge and then we talk in a couple of days.
Okay.
Guys, that's all you got to say.
That's the whole step.
That's the deal.
You're going to get a couple of jobs.
First of all, I have a hot lead.
That's why I'm calling you, just to follow up from last step.
Okay.
And I would like to give you three to five for free.
That's what's in it for you.
What's in it for me is I want a conversation.
Are you good if we have a conversation?
Because here's the deal.
You're already spending money.
You're hungry to grow.
I have jobs.
I don't do the work.
You do the work and you need more jobs or you wouldn't be running ads.
So what if I get you a couple for free to prove that I'm not messing around and we talk
in a couple of days?
Okay.
No obligation, no commitment.
The only thing I ask in return is that you talk, is that we have a discussion.
That's it.
Are you good with that?
Cool.
And guys, that's it.
That is it.
And I don't even want to go any further.
Some other things that you can sprinkle in is I do at times, if I'm feeling a little
shaky or I'm a little bit more comfortable, I do like to sprinkle in, I like to name drop.
So let's say I'm targeting St. George.
So at this point, I would be like, maybe they'd say, yeah, I'm down.
I'm cool.
Cause like guys, that's a really, it's a, it's a, it's a no lose.
There's no risk for them, right?
The only risk is if you start saying, oh, it's good, good, good, and you don't explain
what's in it for you, they're going to say, yeah, I'm good because they just think it's
a scam.
Okay.
That's going to translate the scam.
They think it's a scam is going to translate into I'm good or I've got plenty of work.
They're really actually interested because they're running ads.
They just don't understand.
Okay.
At this point, if I'm feeling a little shaky, what I'll say is, Hey, do you guys know the,
you know, XYZ company down the road?
It's totally different.
These guys actually do, they do, they do tree service.
You guys know them?
Yeah.
So yeah.
Tony's a great guy.
Michelle's awesome.
Yeah.
I've been working with those guys for two years doing the exact same thing.
I just send them the jobs.
We have a deal worked out where we, you know, I win, they win, I get paid, they get paid.
It's worked out super nice.
So anyway, so I'll do that.
So if it's somebody in their town, if I'm already working with somebody in St. George
or in Austin or whatever, I'll use, even if it's a different industry, I'll use somebody.
If it's somebody in the industry, I'll just drop the name.
So let's say I'm going, I'm in St. George and I'm targeting a company in Vegas or I'm
targeting company in Vegas, but I have somebody in St. George in Vegas.
I'd say, Hey, I know this is a little bit of a stretch, but you don't happen to know
that company up in St. George, a couple hours wait, it's called Provent.
I know that they've like done a few jobs down there.
Have you bumped into them?
Okay, cool.
Anyway, the guy's name is Joe.
I've been working with him doing something similar, not in your market, but in St. George
for about two years.
It's been awesome, man.
We've been working together forever.
So anyway, beside the point, and that's just a way of me building credibility.
Okay, guys, that's it.
That's the deal.
Again, most important part about explaining the deal is first of all, don't overthink
it.
Just explain.
I'm going to give you a couple of leads.
First of all, I got Janet.
She's hot, baby.
She's ready to roll.
Number one, you're going to explain that.
You're going to say, let me give you a couple for free.
Like literally, the only thing I ask in return is I want to have a conversation.
That's it.
I want to have a conversation about possibly working together.
Explain it.
Then again, we're going to transition after this point if they've agreed and said, yeah,
that sounds good.
I'm okay with that.
Say, oh, awesome.
What's the best email and phone number to send these leads to?
I'm just going to go right into it.
Because if you ask that question and they're not following you, they ain't going to give
you the email.
They're not going to give you the phone number.
Okay?
That's where I'm going to leave this video.
I'll see you on the next one.